hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here welcome to the third
episode of dirty checks tricks against
sicilian
in this lecture i'm going to show you
some of the amazing and wonderful tricks
against sicilian khan as well as
taimanov variation which arises after
the moon order e4 c5 knight to f3 and
now the moon e6
the main line goes as follows white
plays the moon d4
c captures d4 knight captures d4 and
here there is a parting of the vase
the sicilian taimano players will play
the move knight to c6 at this junction
where the sicilian khan player will play
the move a6 at this point
i found many similarities between these
two lines that's why i'm going to
concentrate the tricks where there's a
common setup used by both of the lines
which is
let's say when white respond with the
move knight to c3
black plays the move knight to c6
and any bishop moves for example bishop
to e2 then black plays the move queen to
c7
now first of all i'm going to show you
some of the sideline tricks in this
variations and then we are going to jump
on to the main line
so the first cylinder trick which i want
to show you which is a very cute one
and which helped me to win even against
a very high rated player
here there is a very tricky move
bishop to c4
which at first sight
doesn't make any sense because
this bishop can be easily hit by the
move b5
as the main line goes that black is
going to play queen to c7 anyways
there is a nice discovery on this bishop
when this knight is moved
so what exactly white is up to
well white has a very sneaky move at
this point that is
knight capture c6
now black can obviously capture with
either of the pawn and the game will
continue
but some of the taimano player will
tempt it to take with the queen because
it can easily hit the bishop and when
white defend this bishop with the move
let's say queen to e2
then they can get this initiative move
that is
b5 and it looks like
black is doing so good
but
there is a big problem
and the problem is
this one boom
so
white is winning the rook straight away
not to mention black cannot capture this
bishop because if black captures the
bishop then black will lose a queen
so this is a very cute trap exist in
sicilian taiwan or variation
the second sideline trap i want to show
you let's start with the move bishop to
f4
the idea is to stopping queen to c7 move
and what i found out is some of the
sicilian khan player will churn out the
move knight g to e7 at this point
and this especially happened in quick
games where black is looking forward for
the move d5
unfortunately this move has a big flaw
and
this can be exploited magnificently by
white's amazing peace sacrifice that is
knight d to b5
bam
so you can already see what is looking
for a checkmate threat on the d6 square
so obviously black has to accept this
piece sacrifice
and after knight captures b file the
threat remain as it is
so it looks like the only way to parry
this threat is to play the move d5
but this is exactly white once
now i want you to pause the video at
this point and find out a continuation
where white can actually win the black
queen
okay i hope you find this one that is
bishop to c1 attacking the queen so
queen has the only place to go that is
queen to d7
and now after knight to d6
the king has no place to go except black
has to give up the queen
so these are some of the nice sideline
tricks against
sicilian khan and taimanov variation
now let's see a main line trick in this
variations
now the main line goes as follows white
plays the move knight to c3 black plays
either of the move for example a6 or
queen c7
let's say in this game black plays the
move a6 first and after white reply with
the move bishop to e2
black plays the move queen to c7
here white will continue with the move
bishop to e3
black
continue with the move knight to f6
and after white castle on the king side
black plays this amazing move that is
bishop to b4
so idea is to capturing the knight
doubling the white pawn and then
capturing the e4 pawn
so what white is going to do about it
well here white has this amazing trick
starting with the move
knight to a4
at first side it looks completely stupid
because you are attacking that knight
and that knight run away straight away
and then
most of your opponent
think that oh
probably he missed that i can capture
the e4
well that is exactly why it wants
because the trick is set right here
now there's one thing i like to mention
that if black do not capture the pawn
and if black plays the normal move such
as
castle on the king side then after
knight capture c6
pawn captures
and f4
white initiative is running on the
king's side not to mention black cannot
capture this pawn at this junction
because after
queen to d4 black will lose a piece
so that's why
at this point
most of your opponent
definitely going to capture the pawn and
thinking that you have made a big
mistake
but see yourself
the following moves are very forceful
one and it almost give you a winning
advantage
so to illustrate this i like to show you
one of my own game where i kick start
with capturing the knight on the c6
now
black needs to be very careful over here
black cannot casually capture this
knight with the pawn for example if b
captures c6 then after queen to d4 black
is going to lose a piece
so the only move left is queen capture
c6
after this we are going to play the move
knight to b6 so another forcing move
rook has to move somewhere
my opponent responded here with the move
rook to b8
now the third
forcing move that is queen to d4 so
attacking this b4 bishop as well as the
g7 pawn so the only defense left is
bishop to f8
now the fourth attacking move that is
bishop to f3
attacking the e4 knight which cannot be
moved
so here black has the only two replies
left
if black plays the move f5 over here
then after bishop to h5
he has to move his king because the g7
pawn is spin
so let's say after king to d8 and rook a
to d1
it is the white who has
the pcs are placed so much aggressively
and look at the pathetic development of
the black pieces they are just sleeping
at the back side
so this cannot be good
so most of your opponent here will play
the move d5
and now we have the strongest move of
the game that is
c4
so what white is aiming for is to
destroying the pawn chain which is
supporting that knight
the only good move here for the black is
to play the move bishop to c5 which is
counter attacking the white queen
but once again the continuations are
very much forceful
so here white will continue with the
queen captures g7 attacking the rook
and after rook to f8
can you guessed it
yup is knight captures d5 boom
only two moves needs to be considered if
bishop captures e3 then the simplest is
knight to f6 jack
and after king to e7
we have the easiest move in the world
that is f captures e3 so not only
regaining a piece but that knight on e4
will be gone soon
so that is not good for the black and
if
black obviously going to play the move e
captures d5 which has happened in my
game
i captured the d5 pawn with the c pawn
attacking the queen
my opponent captured the d5 pawn
and now after bishop captures e4 queen
catches e4 and bishop captures c5
not to mention there's a threat of rook
to even
combining with the move queen captures
f8 and black cannot parry both of them
so my opponent resign at this point
i hope you enjoy this wonderful tricks
in the khan and taimano mainline
variations
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and i'll meet you in my next
episode
bye